l'environnement est le troisième salon
des énergies renouvelables à lyon elles
ont le vent en poupe c'est le cas de le
dire le nombre de chauffe eau solaire
par exemple installé l'an passé a
augmenté de 50% 8000 au total c'est l'un
des équipements les plus utilisés dans
ce domaine
ça n'est pas le seul à bergheim près de
colmar reportage christine bost
jean-pierre pasteur en plein vignoble
alsacien cette maison écolo high tech
est un objet de curiosité
de par son concept on est chauffée on
est rafraîchie en est et si on le désire
et on a de l'eau chaude tout sa part et
le soleil et par la chaleur de la terre
et en même temps au niveau environnement
on abîme rien du tout et pour cela 30
mètres carrés de panneaux
photovoltaïques absorbent l'énergie
solaire pour produire de l'électricité
revendue 15 centimes d'euro le
kilowattheure à edf
de quoi alléger les factures
d'électricité plus classique des
panneaux solaires pour chauffer l'eau
complètent l'installation
d'ailleurs plus de 8000 de ses chauffe
eau solaires ont été installés en france
en 2004 un geste significatif pour
l'environnement installer un chauffe eau
solaire individuel chez soi ça va éviter
environ une tonne à une peine 5 de co2
tous les ans et c'est en gros ce que
produit votre voiture individuelle quand
elle parcourt 10000 km chez les mères tu
la démarche écologique ne s'est pas
arrêté là pour le chauffage de leur
maison ils ont eu recours à la
géothermie la chaleur naturelle du sous
sol du jardin est acheminé vers la
maison grâce à une pompe à chaleur
résultat une maison spacieuse
confortable et écologique
je crois qu'on a quand même réussi à
faire quelque chose qui soit en accord
avec ce qu'on vaut le faire avec notre
rêve
respecter l'environnement mais la vertu
écologique a un coût soixante quatre
mille euros pour les équipements et leur
installation